[Music]
hi
david and thank you for joining me first
of all
what is narco capitalism can you give us
a general overview of what that means
it's a society which does not have a
government
and does use private property and trade
to coordinate
so if you think about the most extreme
pro-free market position you're used to
which says well all the government
should do is police courts
and national defense anarcho-capitalism
is carrying the argument one step
farther
and replacing the fundamental government
functions with market functions
and it differs from what i think of as
left anarchy
in that it uses proper private property
and trade
as the main mechanism for coordination
but the
problem in my view with the inaugural
communist or the anarcho-syndicalist
problem
is they don't really have a solution to
the problem of how
in a world where millions of people have
to coordinate their activity to do
anything
how you manage that sort of anonymous
large-scale coordination
without the system of
prices and and and property that we now
use to do it
so what makes you think that this
structure is an arc capitalist world um
would be a better place to live in
yeah there are two different questions
one of them one is
would it be a better place and what is
would it work but in terms of the better
place
the argument is that while people think
about government in terms of what it
could do or what it says it does
if you actually look at what government
does it on the whole makes things worse
not better so if you think in general
for example in the us
there was a lot of talk about how we
needed to do things about covid
the first thing the u.s government did
was to forbid people from using any
tests except the one they put out
and then to discover after a few weeks
of the one they put out didn't work
that would be one very small example but
in general i think that governments
that the way i put it in my talk
is we need some way of making people who
make
of getting people who make decisions
have an incentive to make the right
decision
and on the market we do that pretty well
because if you want to
produce something you've got to pay for
your input so you've got to compensate
for the people who are providing those
inputs for the cost to them of the
inputs
you get paid for your output so at least
roughly speaking
the net gain to you is the net gain to
everybody the value of what you've
reduced minus the cost
people are producing it that's not true
in the political system in the political
system
most people who make decisions neither
bear the cost
nor receive the benefit of the decision
and the result is that political
decisions tend to be made
for reasons that have very little to do
with whether they actually make us
better off and i could give
lots of examples but that's sort of the
general argument
the particular the detailed point for an
anarcho-capitalism
is to apply that argument to law as well
as everything else
the first part of the argument i think a
lot of conservatives would on the whole
agree with uh that their socialism works
badly capitalism works well it's
not everybody agrees with it obviously
but it's a fairly widespread belief
but most people believe that fundamental
things like law and law enforcement have
to be done by government
and the inaugural capitalist view is
that for the same reason governments do
a bad job of producing food
with the result that when governments
are in charge of producing and
distributing food there is likely to be
a famine has happened a couple of times
in my lifetime
well once in my lifetime once just
before my lifetime actually
uh that similarly if governments are in
charge of making law
they're likely to do a bad job of making
law uh
and again one could give examples and
that
therefore if you could find a way of
getting laws made on the market the same
way we
grow potatoes you would be more likely
to get high quality laws and i spent a
good deal of time during my talk
sketching the institutions which would
at least you know which might we don't
really know what will happen but which
might
function to produce the fundamental
government functions privately
how achievable is this uh
in my lifetime almost certainly not in
your lifetime maybe
uh but i think where it's most likely to
happen is not
the world as a whole but those parts of
the world that is hard for governments
to control
so in particular i think that cyberspace
is developing at least some features of
inaugural capitalism
that for example you have contract
enforcement
done mainly by reputation rather than
mainly by legal force
if you look at how ebay organizes things
that basically when you buy something
from ebay
you report to ebay on how it turned out
when someone else wants to buy for the
same seller he sees whether or not most
buyers were satisfied
they've got various mechanisms of that
sort which are avoiding the whole
government legal system
and using the alternative of reputation
which is the sort of thing i would hope
to see
uh and more generally online
national borders are invisible
governments have limited ability to keep
track of what's happening
so i think there's a real possibility
even in my lifetime
that you could have something rather
like a narco capitalism
for the limited world of online commerce
but for more than that i think unless
they solve the aging problem which i
have more in favor of they're doing
every year for obvious reasons
but unless they solve that i don't think
that it's likely to happen in my
lifetime
but i think it's worth putting ideas out
and when you put ideas out eventually
someone may implement them
ronald cost who was a prominent
economist
proposed way back maybe in the 1950s
that instead of having the government
allocate the airwaves
say this radio station is allowed to
broadcast on this frequencies well that
one you should just auction them off
treat them as property and let whatever
radio station
uh could make the most money out of
broadcasting in a particular place by it
and at the time coast made the argument
was obviously an absurd idea nobody
would ever do
and currently it's government policy now
it's not quite as an extreme aversion as
coasters because the current government
policy
they decide what category a particular
frequency range has to be used for
but then they auction off that frequency
range to the highest bidder
so that would be one example i think
where what seemed like a
absurdly optimistic or
unrealistic view happened and in the
other direction in the direction of
things i don't like
uh it's arguable that the most
successful political party in america
was the socialist party
it never won any important elections i
think it elected a mayor of milwaukee
once and that's about the limit
but if you compare their platform
beginning of the 20th century
with the republican the democratic
platforms at the end of the 20th century
you discover that they largely won
and they did it by making certain ideas
popular i think many of them were bad
ideas in my view but that doesn't mean
they didn't work
politically and therefore other people
ended up
implementing those ideas so i guess what
i'm doing is not i'm not
a revolutionary or a reformer i'm not
trying to create institutions
i'm trying to create ideas in the hopes
that other people will eventually make
use of it
where has the closest governmental
system
to that's interesting historically
speaking
there are a fair number of relatively
prim
not primitive made who's strong but of
early societies
in which law enforcement was private and
decentralized
and the one i know best and wrote about
earliest
is saga period iceland this is iceland
about a thousand years ago
and that was a society where there was a
legislature and a court system uh
but there was no government enforcement
there was no executive arm of government
so after you got your verdict it was
basically up to you to enforce it
and that's the system that lasted for
more than 300 years that eventually
broke down as most
systems have it produced a lot of very
fine literature
we get our word saga from the icelandic
sagas which were
historical novels and histories written
in the 13th and 14th century
and if you think about how many of the
sagas are still in print in english
translation
it really puts iceland on a per capita
basis on the same grounds as berkeley
and athens or elizabethan england
it's a tiny population and we're still
reading the things they wrote
700 years later quite a lot of them
so that would be one but there are other
examples that northern somalia
somaliland back before the creation of
the nation of somalia
which was created artificially by italy
and england that was a mistake i think
had essentially a less fancy version of
the kind of society i'm describing in
which there
was no government nominally the english
were in charge but mostly they weren't
and before that they weren't at all and
in which there were private mechanisms
for settling disputes and enforcing the
rules
and there are a number of other such
things my most recent non-fiction book
is a book called
legal systems very different from ours
in which i
look at a whole bunch of different legal
systems
and one of the f it came out of a
seminar i taught every other year at
santa clara university law school for
many years
and one of the fun things was that i
concluded that in my first book where i
sketched out how inaudible capitalism
might work
i was really reinventing the wheel that
is to say i was inventing
in the context of a modern high division
labor of labor kind of society
something a primitive version of which
had existed a thousand years ago
uh probably more than that in various
places
so that's i mean that would be one of
the places
but i don't think you really have an
aqua capitalism
anywhere in the world today but you have
elements of it
that an awful lot of commercial disputes
are settled by private arbitration by
the american arbitration association and
similar groups
rather than by the courts there are
gated communities where people are in
effect providing their own
police protection so i think the answer
is that you've got
bits of it as it were interwoven in a
modern society but you don't have
anything that's a
full scale an aquacopter listen more
very close to it
and why is that why do you think that so
few places
that's a good question capitalism in the
way that you advocate
that's a good question uh i don't know
uh that's the best argument that it
doesn't work
or it isn't workable is that we don't
see it on the other hand if you go back
a couple of hundred years
and you imagine somewhere somewhere
around 1800
who's dreamed up this really weird
society i mean it's a society in which
government is so big
that it takes that it collects and
spends 40 percent of all income
it's a society where everybody can vote
even women
it's a if you go down the list of the
descriptions of the standard modern
western society
none of those existed in 1800
all right so my hope is that as
circumstances change in various ways
what wasn't workable a hundred years ago
may be workable 100 years hence but
we'll have to see
so what concrete steps would you
recommend
uh in the usa and the uk
uh to move towards this
utopia um
sure the i guess the obvious
steps are to make it easier to
privatize things now done by government
so that for example
in the us i'm in favor of a voucher
system for schooling
uh that there's no particular reason
even if we even if government is going
to pay for schooling which may or may
not be a good idea there's no reason why
they should control it
and therefore uh what you ought to do is
to say that if
the government is currently spending
twelve thousand dollars a year on each
school kid
which is about depends on where you are
but somewhere around there
that if a parent will arrange to have
the kid educated somewhere else they
should get that money to
be used to pay for the education and if
you do that i think over a period of
might i suppose 30 or 40 years you will
largely replace the public school system
with a
much more diverse private school system
with different kinds of schools doing
things in different ways
that would be one step in the right
direction uh in general i think that the
court system
should be more willing than it is to
recognize freedom of contracts to take
the position that
contracting parties are allowed to make
their own rules for themselves which
courts were willing to do pretty much in
1900 are much less willing to do in 2000
that would be one example
there are some areas where the
government is both doing bad things
and doing bad things which result
in indirect bad things as it were and
i'm thinking now mainly of the war on
drugs
that i think to begin with preventing
people from taking drugs is a bad thing
that you own your own body and it's up
to you what you put in it
but beyond that at least in the us the
war on drugs results
in no knock raids and all sorts of
unpleasantness where
the government law enforcement is doing
violent things they wouldn't have to do
if it weren't that they were trying to
suppress a very large uh and a lucrative
market
uh and i would have thought we would
have learned that lesson with
prohibition
back in the 1920s but apparently we
didn't
so those would be some of the things
that would move it in the right
direction
but beyond that i think
it isn't really government beyond that
the two things that have to be done or
what i'm doing
at the moment which is to try to spread
ideas
favorable to a less governmental system
and creating alternative institutions
people entrepreneurs finding out ways of
making money
doing things that the government is now
losing money doing
there was a playboy magazine had an
interview with h.l hunt who was a
texas oil millionaire maybe i was a
billionaire there
but a very wealthy man and a very right
wing man and he had a chain of
right-wing radio stations
and the interviewer
assumed that he was subsidizing the
stations and he said oh no those
stations make money
if this country is worth saving it's
worth saving a profit
which i thought was a pretty good line
and whether or not it's true about
it whether the if then part is true
if you want to save the country you have
to find ways of doing it in a profit
because people don't generally do things
at a loss if they can help it
so part of it is entrepreneurs finding
out ways
of substituting for government
activities private activities
that's really interesting what idea
could change or save the world the idea
that you should evaluate institutions by
what you can expect them to do
not by what they could do that i think
that
this is in a sense what the part of the
economics whole public choice theory is
about in the political context but it
wouldn't be limited to politics but
that when economists analyze the market
they say all right you've got a bunch of
individuals each of them has his own
objectives
they will interact in the following way
and this is what will happen
traditionally when they analyze politics
they said what good things can
government do look if government did
this we'd be better off so therefore
give the government the power to do it
and i think abandoning that mistake and
saying in both cases
you have to do your best to figure out
what how will it be in the interest of
individuals to act not how do you want
to act so that for example an argument
is made all the time
is that we need a government in order to
do long-range to make long-range
decisions to
do things that are expensive now but
will benefit the future but you then
think about how politics actually works
and there's no incentive to do that that
if you are the president of the u.s
today
and you do something today that's
politically expensive and the result is
that america is better off 20 years from
now
20 years from now you're long out of
office 50 50 chances of
the president of the other party uh
and you're more likely to be out office
because you spent your political
resources doing that instead of doing
things that would get you votes
so if you actually look at how
politicians act they
base their decisions mainly on the
effect of the next election
which is sensible to do and so if you
have an issue like global warming for
example
they tell a good story about how we've
got a sacrifice now for the future
it's conceivable that they're right that
it does good i'm somewhat skeptical i
think people exaggerate the amount of
danger in global warming but i could be
wrong but the reason they're doing it
is not that they care about what happens
50 years from now when they're going to
be dead
it's they think they can get political
benefit by doing it now
after all if you have a carbon tax
that's a new source of revenue
government politicians always like to
have money to spend
and just like the rest of us uh so
uh if you're in a poor third world
country
you'd like to push the idea of global
warming in order to persuade the rich
countries to give you some money
so i think if you if you ask on any of
these issues
not what you not what could government
do that's good or what would you like
government to do
but what's the best theory you can offer
as to what government will do i think
that's
that's an attitude that is worth worth
promoting
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
tv